this is why i this is why i'll be
shocked
because the league belongs to lebron
james and i know we had a nice back and
forth
conversation about giannis and mvp and
and lebron said he was pissed off that
you know he got he was in second place a
distant second place no chance at first
okay that's great that's that's about
hardware
and and kevin durant weighing in that's
all about hardware
but lebron james is about to go
to his 10th nba finals
and you think about i mean how amazing
that is mike
he's been in the league this is right
but okay
but here's the thing about russell this
is why it's amazing for lebron
at the age of 35 at 35 bill russell said
lat played his last game player coach
averaged nine points a game this last
season i think 10 9.9 9.9
points per game he's a player coach
okay see you later i'm done at 35.
lebron at 35 is giving you 25 points to
10 assists
but on top of that bill russell when he
first came into the league
he started he came in as a champion they
won a championship
his first year lebron
coming in it took him like three or four
years
just to establish this team as a playoff
team and i think they got to the finals
in like oh seven so that's what like
year four
the first finals appearance yeah so it's
still the worst team to ever make the
finals
absolutely michael smith you ain't you
ain't lying you ain't lied yet
oh my goodness what a terrible team that
was
wow uh they you know what they lost four
games they should have lost eight
i don't know it's just so bad
uh uh but anyway this this is
lebron james's league no matter what
this uh
the mvp count is no matter what the
all-nba count is
he determines where everything is going
and so i just don't think
well that's the denver nuggets or
anybody else right now
have the ability i feel you on that take
this away from them they can't take it
away all right let's
let's be presumptuous let's let's be
presumptuous and let's let's okay
10th 10th finals appearance nice round
number i mean
first of all it's not just that he
didn't make it until 007
is that he's done it with the calves
the heat the calves and now the lakers
so
you know different from jerry west or
magic johnson
or bill russell and sam jones and those
60 celtics he's done it with
three different franchises but four
different teams let's call it that way
all right four different periods
he lebron alone is a dynasty
we talk about the celtics dynasty we
talk about the lakers dynasty
you talk about the bulls dynasty which
is very much michael jordan
but you always talk about dynasties
within the context of franchises
lebron is an individual walking
living breathing dynasty until further
notice it's why i didn't get all behind
and bothered
about the fact that he wasn't mvp i'm
like it was a 2019-20
season regular season mvp
lebron james has the throne
and until he decides
like hakeem in the subway to renounce
his throne
you're right it's his league and that
matters more
than how many first place again first
place votes he got we're going to be
it's his league it's incredible 10 f 10
finals
10. i will i will say and probably not
done going
don't have to be making three and six
miss me with the three and six
i can't stand people that look at the
record three and six
i know that's the record yeah the
numbers do lie sometimes three and six
like to me six to no is great but
there's something to be said for going
nine going on ten times
i mean my goodness well i will i know
you you're going to have a real problem
with this
as as i say this okay i'm going to see
that don't see it in your face
no i'm going to say it what oh i can't
say something you're going to have a
problem with i'm going to push you a
little bit
but push it all ahead
you mentioned lebron taking the
cavaliers to the finals
two separate times two separate sense
yep one
okay one after the owner said
he will never win this self-proclaimed
king will never win
before uh before we do wrong okay that's
wrong
so he did twice with cleveland he went
with miami he's about to go with the
lakers
i will tell you michael smith i don't
think that lebron james is the best
player i've ever seen in nba history
but he is the only player capable of
doing that
i don't think michael jordan could have
done that
i don't think magic johnson could have
done that i'm no
it's also easy to say it's also easy to
say it's all so easy to say
it's easy to tell me
unless you want to hold the fact that
michael jordan didn't take the
washington wizards to the finals
then okay magic johnson didn't play for
any other teams you know in his prime
now you want to if you want to recognize
lebron for having
an endless prime which it seems like he
does that's one thing
but if michael jordan bounced around the
league if tim duncan had bounced around
the league
if shaquille o'neal had bounced around
the league in his prime and even look
what he did for miami when he went there
if kobe bryant had left the lakers don't
tell me that those dudes wouldn't have
gone to the finals no chad don't tell me
no not not like that
not four different teams no no couldn't
done it it's a space they wouldn't move
four different times it's a special
skill